welcome guardians
this year we're celebrating our journey
with you whether you joined us 30 years
ago or if it just started today
this game is in our blood the destiny
team is full of destiny fans folks who
came here because destiny was their
favorite hobby folks who log out from
work in the evening and log in to play
with their clan the team we have today
is committed to relentlessly upgrading
this game that we all love we aren't
happy with just another mission instead
we want to push the limit of quality you
can expect in an action mmo with
uniquely destiny experiences like
expunge and presage we are committed to
delivering the best mission content that
you can play in any game with a friend
and having the best feeling action game
period
[Music]
and this shows through in the passion
that we see for destiny 2. since we
declared independence two years ago the
destiny community has grown by over 20
million new players and it continues to
grow faster than we ever could have
predicted
we're grateful to be a part of this
amazing growing community that you all
have created you represent destiny you
help make it better every year and you
are so welcoming and supportive of every
new guardian that sets foot in the tower
and only a handful of us are going to be
up here today
most of them are in their homes at their
desks working hard to bring the next
part of destiny to life it's a huge
honor representing such an incredible
team and introducing the next chapter of
destiny 2.
so
without further ado
this
is the witch queen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
truth
is a funny thing
does it live in the world
or in the mind
is it constant
or can it be bent
who decides
what is true
in this universe of light and dark
there is no greater power
tell me little lights
what is your truth now
oh my god james sabathune is serious i
think she's the most dangerous villain
we faced yet seven years we've been
building up to this moment and she is
finally stepping into the spotlight and
showing us who she really is
what we know about light and darkness is
proving to be way more complex than what
we previously thought there are so many
lies truths and revelations that we're
going to get to in the witch queen and
the year leading up to it i mean we're
paying off these narrative threads that
go all the way back to destiny's origins
and we're supporting it with the best
content that destiny has to offer
definitely and we've got a lot of
awesome content to show today let's
start with the most mysterious
destination yet
savithun's throne world this is an
uncharted wonderland of secrets and lies
it's this place that she's created in
her own image the surreal and majestic
light blessed world she has this castle
that she rolls from it overlooks this
dark swampy underbelly with this lone
pyramid ship out there it's the future
world she wanted to create built to top
the darkness that she left behind in
throne worlds they're a deep part of
destiny lore powerful entities create
these pocket universes and when we're
there we have to play by their rules but
now our own light powers are being used
against us i mean she has this whole
army of hive that she's ascended to the
light and brought along with her
these are the hive guardians and they
are the backbone of her new army
we've talked a lot let's show a little
let's take the first ever look at the
witch queen gameplay
the witch queen
hive god of cunning and lies
after the death of her brother oryx
[Music]
savathune went into hiding
not out of fear of course
but out of strategy
in her greatest trick yet
stealing our most sacred resource
the one thing we thought she could never
touch
the light
[Music]
so
[Music]
i cannot wait just to reach out and just
crush a hive ghost in my hand yeah i
mean we've been defined by the light for
so long this is uncharted territory for
us i mean we're in strange new places
like the throne world is haunting but
it's gorgeous it's beautiful there's a
lot to love there's a few things we saw
on the trail that we haven't talked
about yet savathun and her loosened
brood this is the biggest threat
guardians have faced yet so we need to
find new weapons to match their power
the glaive
i love this thing it's brutal and
elegant it's this new energy weapon with
melee abilities mid-range projectiles
and defensive capabilities it's our
first ever first person melee weapon and
it is such an awesome tool for the
battlefield
the glade feels so good just jump in and
unleash these brutal melee combos and
transition right to an energy blast
it's really powerful and has a lot of
utility so we've told you about what the
glaive can do
now let's talk about how you're gonna
get your hands on one these weapons
don't come out of chest at the end of
missions and you're not gonna find one
roaming around the throne world
your first glaive is not going to be
found it's going to be built yes weapon
crafting is coming to destiny 2.
now chasing weapons has been an integral
part of the destiny pursuit game since
the beginning and over the years we've
added more deterministic paths to get
the roles that you want on guns think
things like umbral engrams and the raid
chest weapon crafting unlocks the
freedom to choose all that and more it
gives us ultimate control over the guns
now this is a combat focused crafting
and progression system that means the
more you use these weapons the more
objectives you complete with them the
more you'll level them up and the more
powerful they grow over time and at
launch here's the awesome thing you'll
be able to craft all throne world
weapons new raid weapons and the
seasonal weapons there's just a ton of
stuff to do in this system and the witch
queen is just the beginning of weapon
crafting we have plans to add more
craftable weapons both legacy and new
throughout the year we've seen and we've
talked about a lot of really cool
features but let's get right into the
meat of it let's talk about the witch
queen campaign
i
love campaigns they've always been a
cornerstone of the destiny experience
they're rich deep stories interwoven
with big combat sequences and memorable
characters they take us to remote worlds
in our ever-changing universe and so
we're putting extra care into the
campaign for the witch queen we want you
to feel those goosebumps when you step
onto the throne world for the first time
and come face to face with hive
guardians
and every one of the missions has its
own unique fantasy like what does it
feel like to storm a castle or just go
straight to the depths of hell if you
like games with standalone campaigns
like doom titanfall 2 god war and halo
then the witch queen is for you
so in addition to our classic normal
mode legendary is our tougher
aspirational version of the campaign
where the enemies hit harder and
respawning is heavily restricted so
every battle is a gut punch every boss
is a worthy adversary it's gonna hurt
you might tap out but if you persist and
you get to the end your time will be
well rewarded whether you want to play
solo or with a fire team the difficulty
will scale based on how many people you
bring
before we go one last trip down memory
lane i remember camping out the predator
for destiny 1 because i just had to have
the ghost to me it was like the symbol
of destiny and if you care about that
stuff like me you're going to want to
get your hands on the collector's
edition because you're going to get a
high buddy to go up on the shelf with it
[Music]
[Music]
wow that was so cool i'm so i'm so
excited for this one and that's not even
everything that's in there too i know
those are the hero items and they're i
think one of the best ones that we've
ever done collector's editions have
always been like this really perfect
jumping point to enter the worlds that
we build and
actually lifting like in-world objects
and putting them in players hands is
just it's just a good feeling we don't
just put random items everything in
there means something and it helps push
the narrative and there might be some
puzzles to unlock in there as well
so at this point you can see sabathune
has been one of our greatest threats
operating behind the scenes for years
you may have heard of her brother the
taken king but sabathun is the most
dangerous being we've ever faced she's
cunning elusive she works in the shadows
so in a way sabathun is new to all of us
exactly and now it's time to finally see
this legend reveal herself and change
the destiny universe forever
but when we talk about the overarching
story of destiny we don't just mean the
plot lines or characters that future
release to release narrative is a
guiding force in destiny and we're
calling on its rich history of world
building bringing that to the forefront
and growing it in a bold new direction
so when you join the game today you'll
experience an immediate call to action
alongside millions of your fellow
guardians during this past year we
watched the results of your actions play
out across destiny's seasonal releases
you've redeemed old foes brought former
enemies to the bargaining table learned
that there's always more than one side
to every story and built alliances no
one ever thought possible and on the
largest scale you'll experience a vast
living interconnected world of stories
that's driving to a greater end
you'll experience this alongside a
massive community of guardians release
after release together this is our
universe's cosmic purpose this 10-year
journey we've been on since destiny 1.
it's drawing to its dramatic conclusion
the light and darkness saga will end
but make no mistake destiny 2 will not
we're building not so much to an ending
but more to this transformative moment
for destiny 2's future last year we
announced the witch queen and the
following expansion lightfall and now
we're excited to announce the release
after lightfall the final chapter in the
light and darkness saga
destiny 2
the final shape
it's going to be one wild continuous
ride yes and that ride starts with
season of the lost not only is it the
prologue to the witch queen it's your
first opportunity to interact with
sabathune but
rather than spoil it for you why don't
we take a look
if we are to survive the coming storm
the tower and the dreaming city must
stand united
[Music]
we are surrounded a ring of spears
pointing inward from the edges of our
system
[Music]
the witch queen is no less dangerous now
than she has ever been we must uncover
whatever secrets she knows with the time
that we have
[Music]
we light the pathways of the ascendant
plane and guide my people back to me
there is a malevolent force at work in
this playing guardian
[Music]
your knack for violence is needed
[Music]
[Music]
so
perhaps with them i can save us all
[Music]
seasons have gone through massive
transformations since shadow keep we're
dedicated to creating an evolving
interconnected world that puts your
guardian at the center of the action
we're reaching the end of one journey
and the beginning of another the days of
destiny's biggest story moments
happening in lore pages is long gone i
mean mara's return has been hinted at
forever and now it's happening in a
season
one of the changes i'm most excited
about are the updates to the light
subclasses every season in year five of
destiny 2. we're adding aspects and
fragments similar to stasis we'll be
starting with a void subclass update
that goes live alongside the witch queen
but the witch queen is only the
beginning of what's to come and season
of the lost is the prologue to that
story it starts off with marasob's
return to the dreaming city and with her
return all the awoken technology comes
alive
but the hive god of war zebra wrath has
reemerged and has guardians and mara and
her sights guardians must forge a path
through the ascendant plane to save mars
lost covenant of witches before zebra
wrath can reach them and to aid you in
this task you'll have the wayfinder's
compass the time is at hand the beacon
is shining bright and the ley lines are
set in place
it's an ancient awoken artifact that
gives the wielder the power to uncover
pathways secrets and treasures within
the ascendant plane
there's a plethora of new weapons coming
including a suite of legendary stasis
guns that'll stop your enemies cold
the armor makes you feel like you're a
member of queen mars court and no season
is complete without new exotics and
season velocity features one once
intended for aldrin
let's take a moment to talk about trials
so trials of osiris is the end game
aspirational pvp activity and more
popular than ever two of the biggest ass
from our community have been adding
anti-cheat and adding matchmaking in
season of the lost we're doing both
we've partnered with battlelight to soft
launch the anti-cheat software when
trials goes live on september 10th
also you'll be able to match make with
groups of players to form fire teams or
solo queue by yourself and we've remixed
how rewards are distributed to give all
players the opportunity to earn some of
the best weapons and coolest armor in
the game that's right we're shifting
away from winning matches as a primary
way to earn loot and instead winning
individual rounds and completing matches
will allow you to earn some rewards but
going flawless hasn't changed so if you
want to flex those pvp skills the
flawless chest will still be the only
place to earn a depth trials weapons and
unique cosmetics
all right so the next chapter in destiny
begins right after this stream was
season of a loss return to the dreaming
city with marasov and learned the mystic
art of wayfinding i'm so excited cross
play is going live today and today is
your first opportunity to jump into
destiny with friends on any platform
from all over the world playing together
[Music]
it's pretty devastating as we look at
the racism in america and our intention
is to do better and to leave the world
in a better place we want to be a part
of that social change [ __ ] racism
we don't just stop with the games that
we make but we really utilize the
successes that we've seen to be able to
give back in an even greater capacity
that spans beyond just the gaming
industry
foundation thank you
[Music]
pressing button for live
destiny servers in live this adventure
has begun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this game is single-handedly destroy my
social life and i can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
all right guardian time to kick them
where it hurts
how do you follow that wow
30 years and i i remember when halo
first launched and my friends and i
completed the entire campaign in a
single epic play session and as the
credits rolled i knew that bungie had
transformed council gaming forever and
that i would be a lifelong fan yeah
changed how we played games too i
remember getting together with friends
for halo week and lan parties we had so
much fun
and 30 years of bungee games is
something special it's something worth
celebrating together so we're going to
have a party in destiny 2.
starting this december we are launching
the bungie 30th anniversary celebration
in destiny 2. free for all players the
30th anniversary celebration will offer
a new six player matchmade activity
secrets to unravel and rewards that
commemorate our long and storied history
together and that's just the beginning
in addition to the free event players
can also purchase the bungie 30th
anniversary pack that includes a new
treasure-themed three-player dungeon set
on the cosmodrome within the fabled loop
cave players will plunder its depth to
discover an exciting new thorn inspired
armor set and fan favorite destiny one
weapons like izaluna and thousand yard
stare it even has the claymore sword
from myth purchase in the pack unlocks a
range of awesome bungee themed arm
ornaments and cosmetics to collect
including ornament sets inspired by the
bungee 30th anniversary celebration and
marathon but the dungeon holds one more
secret the crown jewel of its weaponry
is a destiny one classic gallahorn is
making its long-awaited debut in destiny
2.
we're going to take its iconic status to
the next level galley has been carefully
updated for the destiny 2 sandbox so
this december join your friends and
collect exclusive rewards during the
bungee 30th anniversary celebration but
the party isn't only happening in
destiny 2. we've partnered with nerf
limited to create a functional dart
firing gallow horn we'll have more on
that soon and that's not all here's a
look at some of the incredible loot
we've made over the years and a sneak
peek of what's coming up
[Music]
wow lorraine i can't believe we're
celebrating bungie's 30th anniversary 30
years it's incredible yeah i mean look
think of all the games and products that
have come out over these years yeah
starting operation desert storm pathways
into darkness
marathon myth
oni halo and destiny seven years of
destiny it's an amazing journey
so excited you know we have a lot of
really cool stuff coming up and a lot of
other things in the works of course as
always but yeah i mean what do we have
we have the fallen captain statue which
is incredible and then we have the
helmet celestial night i think it's so
cool yeah and my favorite the arcadia
jump ship yeah i get goosebumps just
thinking about that you know it really
gives me that nostalgia from destiny 1
and so i think it's a great way that
we're going to celebrate not only
bungie's 30-year heritage but the seven
year heritage of destiny yeah and it
definitely gives you the feels
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for being on this journey with
us whether it started this year or 30
years ago we've just started talking
about the witch queen today you've got
our first peek at weapon crafting our
definitively destiny campaign the glaive
and a year full of updates to all our
light base type classes
all of this and more is coming alongside
savathun's long awaited arrival front
and center to the destiny universe
the witch queen marks an acceleration in
our story heading towards the conclusion
of the light and dark saga and we're so
excited for everyone to join us on this
epic adventure in the witch queen
lightfall the final shape and beyond
and the witch queen's gonna kick off
another amazing year of destiny with
four great seasons packed with all of
the narrative events and rewards that
you've come to expect from us but
there's even more coming next year than
just our new seasons
the deluxe edition of the witch queen
will also include two brand new dungeons
to be released in 2022 and we're also
going to be remastering another classic
destiny one raid and releasing it free
for all players this means going forward
starting this december with our 30th
anniversary event there will be a new
piece of raider dungeon content in the
game every three months
[Music]
in 2022 we will also be adding legacy
rotations for rage and dungeons meaning
every week there will be new ways to
earn rewards in both the latest and
greatest content and raids and dungeons
from the past if you love amazing
in-game content we want to prove that no
other game offers more quality and more
variety than destiny 2.
we hope that you've enjoyed a look into
the future of destiny 2. which queen
pre-orders are available wherever you
play destiny cross play is live on all
devices and season of the lost kicks off
today
see you in games
[Music]
is a funny thing
who decides what is true
tell me little lights
what is your truth now
the witch queen is no less dangerous now
than she has ever been
prepare for what is inevitably to come
[Music]
[Music]
you